non tous de s'exprimer aujourd'hui
instants pour une petite compilation de
jeux et c'est quoi ces jeunes et on
commence tout de suite avec l'oc slinger
voilà un jeu dans lequel la chance est
au coeur du jeu ou où je crois que ça
commence donc moi je suis mais que le
cow boy finalement je suis pas canal ce
qui aurait été un peu moins fun et le
jeu basé sur la chance en fait on
ramasse des essences de chance si je
puis me permettre au jeu vu ça avant
bordel et des essences de malchance
voilà et ça va influer sur ce qui se
passe autour de moi a donc là par
exemple il me dit que j'ai passé des
sources de champs ce qui veut dire qu'il
peut se passer des événements malchance
le voilà par exemple les pierres qui se
barrent là c'est bon et a cette chance
dedans et du coup il peut se passer des
événements de chance grand cheveux aux
dons à ok il ya une cuisse de poulet qui
est sorti du mur pour me sauver par
exemple il y attend et je fasse quoi la
cua a cessé sa séquence à pas de chance
bon il y avait plus tard on les voit pas
il se fond dans le décor l'âge est bon
je suis plutôt chanceux au pas tant que
ça c'est marrant comme principal je
passe peut pas être que moi c'est un peu
dommage hein et non mon enfant et non et
non et non au hockey ça ne dévient débat
le carrément quand j'ai de la chance
c'est scandaleux sans déconner à on peut
esquiver les projecteurs dans sa voie là
je l'étais sur des fois tu veux juste
être chanceux à un moment précis
ah ouais ok admettons qu'il reste ou pas
fou c'est pas moi à o o m chatouiller le
dos comme ça je les ai vus elle faisait
comme ça on avance sans ça me gratte et
c'est un clippeur de minecraft dead or
alive side
il a braqué une banque et ward une barbe
d'or oui pourra s'acheter des billets
des coeurs [ __ ] je monte sur mon
cheval et je m'en vais je monte sur mon
cheval j'ai dit je tue mon cheval
j'ignore mon cheval ça y'a pas de
problème
ah ben voilà on pouvait monter bordage a
été sûr je montre le cheval on s'en va
retrouver sinon maltais foncé aux up à
bas la vipère mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive tetris un âge et vu compris
truc le truc à temps mais c'est une
blague ou quoi ils marchent pas les
danses qu'au fond mais non ok on a passé
le camp français on va totalement ignoré
le coffre au tien attends attends je
vais donner mon couteau planté dans lui
en mon dieu ça sent le boss ont motivé
la rive attend dé nous ils me double
j'ai entendu que tu me cherches
exactement tu t'appelles loxley girl
c'est ça oui vu que tu as un temps
limité j'ai décidé de faire mon
apparence et fit qu'un peu plus tôt
prévu normalement je suis tout en bas de
ce chemin super loin et tout c'est ici
que notre journée à chaîne avait alors
le caractère du mec quoi allez trève de
bavardages te baise attend c'est fini
mais non mais non
ah oui ok c'est une des mots des mots
quoi je peux même pas tuer le boss m'a
très bien bas là bas il en liberté j'ai
pas la barre d'ordre est compromis c'est
le truc que j'ai c'est la barre deux
rives
nous sommes maintenant sur les mejor age
2 un jeu de parcours dans lequel on va
se plaire l'oeil stick to move relating
to lose you [ __ ] c'est sur ces gars
mon style et ça fait bien pour ça mais
envisage effectivement right wing à
toudja aux eaux et whip fatwa 63 60 dans
tous les jeux bon jour j'avais oublié de
régler la caméra vous êtes content un
mot ici non mais regardez ça et oui
c'est vrai se déforme regarder ou irrite
pital choisi son bras l'espace 10 de
seconde 3 or ben oui la quatrième marque
s'il vous plaît messieurs
ah oui est ce là dessus et je me disais
oh c'est pas voilà peut-être qu'elle a
un exosquelette qu'on ne voit pas
finalement à longny vallée ma allez
allez allez et fait attention aux pattes
raté puisque sinon c'est l'hématome
oui on a fait beaucoup dans cette vidéo
il est vrai mais bon ça nous plaît on
continue à un tas ça fait tellement
plaisir de jouer un jeu ou aux mondiaux
machar effectivement pour pouvoir sauter
entre deux murs au l'homme est excusé
situe le j'espère que tu as ce message à
tort ne viens pas ici s'il te plaît fais
moi confiance
ça va aller ça l'est mais on peut le
faire carrément s est quand même bien
stylé ça fait plaisir c'est leur
victoire en sièges de sorte en fait j'y
arrive johan tu as dit à venir mais je
vais venir comme dans tous les films
d'action hollywoodiens
parce que j'ai peur qu'il lui arrive
malheur oreille alors bon
au supplice qui est notamment pour faire
du parcours un peu à attend la diction
smartphone c'est même dans les jeux
maintenant ça suffit
elles seraient connus chez tran qui fait
on ne s'assoit pas des jeux fait que de
faire droit aux oies ou seboa en fait
sourire faux j'avais pas vu mais elle
est dans l'excès cette fille quoi rien
qu'en mal course avec eux des halles et
le manager une baisse de tension je
trouve pratique et là haut c'est
tellement style et c'est le même moule
que dans mirror's edge un hall alors
regardez moi ça on gratte le mur
littéralement et avant de tomber dans le
vide et de mourir au lol moi c'est
pendant ces bandes ont comme barres de
fer non autorisée libyen stop motion
mais c'était la merde presque plastique
just before l'indiquent de préval fall
dos mais jack sillage fait ok j'ai rien
compris aux plats mais oui j'ai amorti
le choc
cet homme dormira à apprendre à dire
c'est en bus que c'est comme dans
mirror's edge
c'est quoi ça ça fait flipper j'avais
créé par partout aujourd'hui mais c'est
abusé non avec sa lettre aux partout
mais du coup il fait des petits un con
si vous avez plus à moi je pratique la
sécu de la mulatière que je t'ai tout en
roulade et j'adore ça regarde
effectivement on peut le constater on
peut voir que le fait de la roule avec
ça me sauve la vie même dans les sons
les plus forts
ça donne bien la gerbe quand même jeu
suivant nous sommes maintenant sociaux
smythe un jeu qui développe totalement
notre paranoïa
en bref y'a plein de gens là et y en a 1
voilà des fois il s'arrête et on est on
doit trouver qui veut nous tuer il faut
lui tirer dessus et avant qu'ils nous
tirent dessus
gresh totalement par notre aux plages de
baisers aux plages les baisers aux
plages les baisers j'ai paniqué ok donc
faut attendre que ya pas une estimation
et ensuite il sort son pistolet voilà
son agent est mort je t'avais prévenu
encore des [ __ ] de téléphone qui nous
joue des tours
c'est bon et pourquoi ils ont besoin de
s'arrêter pour répondre à leurs
téléphones bordel comment veux tu que je
n'ai pas de doute après sa puce est faux
dans la rue on s'arrête jamais pour
garder son téléphone on continue de
marcher
des fois même recevoir des poteaux ap ap
la maison mais [ __ ] c'est incroyable
ce jeu était vraiment au mode à l'affût
eau plate est mort fils de chien de
sequana pas que tu vas sortir de ta
poche mais attention à toi moment au
maire c'est un téléphone jamais aux
ottomans
ils étaient trop nombreux mais c'est pas
poussé que vous avez battu presque à son
café il est plus de prolifération ici
que dans une phase avec énervé sur les
connais ton sur un toit jackson à hop là
je t'avais dit de faire attention c'est
incroyable ce jeu il te temps georges tu
ne parle plus tu es complètement
stressée et en plus tu t'en sors tu as
envie de buter les mecs qui sont au
téléphone voilà alors lis que la moyenne
pas très discret quand même cet homme
ait caché celui d'en bas je devrais le
but est aussi en foire et il a une âme
le petit [ __ ] en tout cas celui là
bah voila je l'avais prédit à la bientôt
en plein festival festival ya le
festival de cannes et la festival des
gens qui kahn est désormais au revoir
quoi à temps mais c'est scandaleux mais
comme base le poids exclamations est
apparue demi seconde à ripley je mens
pas brest-valenciennes cette vidéo sur
ses trois petits jeux et bac s qu'ils
étaient style et j'espère qu'ils vous
ont plu aussi si ces cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo comme d'habitude et on se
retrouve très bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo schéma pourquoi je fais ça à
pourquoi du biceps
voilà ça fait travailler un petit peu le
biceps qui es-tu latéral gauche mais ça
vous regardez en soit en attendant une
prochaine vidéo car tout le monde pis
[Musique]
je